have you ever wondered what your
favorite disney royals would look like
if they swapped running a kingdom for
leading a revolution
disney characters definitely have an
irresistible spark about them
but we have to admit there's nothing
quite like the fierceness that comes
along with the hunger games characters
so
what if we could have the best of both
worlds that's right
we're mixing fire and magic and
reimagining your favorite disney
characters as the tributes from district
12
and beyond from ball gowns to battle
suits get ready to see belle's books
turn into bows
and imagine how elsa would look if she
chopped off her locks and traded her ice
gown for
something a little more rebellion ready
maybe i'll
be ever in your favor
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
well the verdict's in and they look epic
these crossovers are on fire literally
while we absolutely love the nostalgia
of our fairy tale classics
maybe it's time for disney to take a
page out of elsa's book and say
let it go to their traditional looks who
wouldn't want to see a princess ready
for a revolution
at this point there's really only one
question left do you think cinderella
would love mahogany as much as effie
we're gonna say yes make sure you let us
know what you think
don't forget to hit that subscribe
button to be notified whenever we post a
video
catch you later
[Music]
you